calculators computers and teachers
throughout your life have told you that
you can't divide by zero but I'm here to
tell you that you
can it's true in the real numbers
division by zero isn't defined but
neither is taking theare root of1 and
yet mathematicians found a way to do it
checking all the details might be a bit
complex But ultimately the idea is just
throw in a number whose square is ne1
then follow the normal rules of algebra
to figure out what this new number
system looks like
if you do this with theare root of1 you
end up with the familiar complex numbers
they might have some weird properties
compared to the reals but they're a
perfectly good system of numbers to work
with can we just do the same thing with
division by zero can we just throw in an
inverse of zero and see what
happens given that you've been told your
whole life that you can't divide by zero
you might expect that for reasons you
don't fully understand you can't just
throw in an inverse of a number the same
way you can throw in a solution to x^2
als1 nope that's not the problem the
process of throwing in the inverse of a
number or set of numbers and seeing what
happens is called localization and it's
no more difficult to do than throwing in
theun of NE
1 suppose you started with the integers
there's no 1/2 in the integers so let's
throw it in in order to be able to
multiply numbers as usual we would also
need to throw in all the multiples of
1/2 including negative 1es and
multiplying 1/2 with itself means we
also need 1/4 and all the multip of a
fourth and so on and so forth we need to
add in anything that's an integer divid
a power of two but then we're good to go
we end up with what are called the datic
or binary rationals which is another
weird but perfectly valid number system
if we also threw in third a fourth a
fifth a sixth inverses of every positive
whole number then we end up with all the
rational numbers ratios of integers
where the denominator is not zero this
is a pretty standard way to construct
the rationals so what about zero
inverse well let's do it let's start
with the real numbers throw in an
inverse of zero and just see what kind
of number system pops out just like a
half is the unique number such that 2 *
a half is 1 our inverse of zero is going
to be the unique number such that 0 *
the inverse of 0 is 1 so let's assume
that's true then what pretty quickly we
see this implies that 1 equals 0 because
anything * 0 is 0 but wait this is not a
contradiction of course in the real
numbers 0 is different than one but in
the real numbers x^2 can never be
negative either and yet we're perfectly
okay in the complex numbers saying that
i^2
is1 just because we've discovered an
unintuitive property of this new number
system that doesn't make it
wrong let's just continue and see where
it takes us take any number X in this
system and note that X is 1 * X because
1 * anything is that thing but because 1
equal 0 this is also 0 * X which of
course is 0 because 0 * anything is 0
Thus We've shown in our new number
system that every number equals
zero there's still no contradiction no
error in logic we've just invented
What's called the zero ring where 0 is
the only number 0 + 0al 0 0 - 0 equal 0
0 * 0 equal 0 0 / 0 equal 0 and 1 is
just another label for
Z feel free to check that this number
system satisfies all the normal rules of
algebra it really does so it's not that
you can't divide by zero it's just that
if you allow it then all numbers are
zero and you get what you
deserve